willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
ein bisschen kassenband hier so falls
man das sieht und ich hab mir gedacht
ist nur kleines info videoarbeit wichtig
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht komm
erstmal so du bist doch hier es bei mir
bei uns liegt schnee okay ich bin noch
in österreich aber ich mir gedacht mach'
ich das mal hier so und um zwar geht es
um eine sache
ihr wisst bestimmt schon ich hab schon
auf instagram und so weiter die porr
sind viele von euch wissen es bestimmt
auch am ersten und zweiten mai sind die
video days in berlin
ich will natürlich auch im staat und
deswegen wollte ich sagen falls ihr in
der umgebung wurden falls ihr auf jeden
fall bock hat mich zu sehen oder noch
ganz viele andere youtuber zu sehen dass
sie noch keine ahnung
die lobbys und so weiter ich packe sie
hier ein bild noch mal kurz ein nicht
auch mal ein und kommt auf jeden fall
vorbei falls ihnen der nebel und würde
mich extrem freuen mal wieder so
ziemlich viele von euch heimat zu sehen
und tickets gibt es auch in der video
beschreibung klickt einfach auf den link
holt euch tickets würde mich sehr freuen
falls ihr vorbeischauen falls euch sehen
könnte und das war's so weit von mir ich
werde jeden tag eine stunde glaube ich
es ist so eine stunde habe ich zeit um
halt an einem bestimmten ort fotos oder
so zu machen mit euch deswegen ich weiß
nicht wie ich das genau ankündigt ich
poste ist auf jeden fall auf instagram
deswegen hier nochmal schnell instagram
eingeblendet check das ab folgt wieder
falls ihr nicht verpassen wollte dann
wisst ihr bescheid wann ich wo bin und
so viel dazu ich kann euch ja noch mal
zeigen wie man sieht nicht viel aber man
sieht ja gar nichts auf jeden fall war
es das von mir leute
wir sehen uns in berlin wer richtig geil
und hat rein